he is currently in whiskey Cavalier that
airs tonight and every Wednesday at
10:00 eastern time on ABC good to see
you the pride of Lexington Kentucky
Johns Hopkins how are you sir I'm
fantastic so now it'll be Rockland help
me out here you sat down you comment on
the man shoes is that what happened over
here oh yes so he's wearing these Larry
Bird edition converse said I noticed
last year at big slick you're wearing
the same ones is that really these are
Larry Bird converges or I got these 15
years ago come on Wow Oh Canada
yeah I'm shooting there and saw these
and I was like bought done mm-hm are you
a Larry Bird guy not not really but more
so now now now I respect this game more
than when I was growing up I was just
like I wanted the Lakers so wipe this
out so are you a sneaker guy
I'm not per se like Imelda Marcos of
sneakers you know I'm not one of those
guys that just has a bunch of shoes that
you never touches I wear the shoes okay
I I get but sometimes I'll see something
and I'm like I gotta have that I have to
so are you the Imelda Marcos of shoes
over there
no I think between me and TJ we got that
market cornered you you don't buy shoes
just to look at right you actually
sometimes shoe flipper I'm a follow shoe
flipper yeah I'm a flipper see downtown
I just won't understand that shoes that
you get that you never wear yeah I yeah
it's the see what other than me I i
apparel for me is to be worn mm-hmm not
kept and looked at mm-hmm right yes sir
it's not like a trading card and I sound
like Gary Vee back yeah a couple weeks
ago but I mean it's not like a trading
card like I just saw but we sound like
get off my lawn I know I know I know I
know what I sound like right now but you
know I can't can only I only know one
speed those look like they're fresh out
of the box oh not bad for fifteen nine
now kudos the converse okay so uh what
did you make of the Kentucky Wildcats
season sir that just ended I has a great
season of course I'd like to see us win
one more and get to the Final Four okay
uh it was a lot of fun to see that team
grow we had tough beginning right and
then a little you know a steady
ascension
to a really good team right you know I
had some injuries right at the end with
PJ that slowed us down a little bit dead
right but uh I mean is one of Calipari
asbestos I thought in Kentucky Mike he's
there for life now I know UCLA came
knocking on his door come out here yes I
didn't appreciate that you went to
Westwood and gave him a piece of your
mom yes I did okay and now he's he's
staying there for life pretty much
that's pretty that's the plan I know
who's your favorite Kentucky Wildcat
player of all time
I'll give you one choice your first
overall draft choice you're nodding head
like you know already who is it Rex
Chapman no kidding Rex Chapman he was a
Kentucky guy yeah just a few years older
me but he was my item why because he was
from Kentucky yes and he had the New
Wave game I mean he could really jumpy
as athletic one of the prettiest jumpers
I've ever seen in my life right and and
he knew and he had a great IQ for the
game too he was just I mean he was just
my hero you didn't even stutter because
there's been hundreds of greats that
come through Kentucky's law for sure did
you follow him on Twitter now of course
you're charged it's it's the greatest
bit on Twitter right it is it's great an
test is it's it is addictive like you
feel a need you have to respond every
single time it's now now I'll get a call
from Susie or a text like have you seen
the latest blocker charge like that's
what I'm getting and I actually dropped
it on the NFL Draft the other night when
when Christian Wilkins gets drafted by
the Miami Dolphins saw and he comes out
and he jumped at the Commissioner and he
just literally went to chest bump a man
who's not ready for charge by the way
that's what I said that was a charge
it's a chip well I'm not sure had his
feet set he had his feet set but then of
course that's the beauty of the blocker
charged conversation is that a lot of
people say in the photograph Roger had
his right heel oh and he was leaning
into the contact his heel was off of the
ground
now the out of the semicircle so it
would have been if he didn't have this
but the the issue the issue is is we're
looking on the screen right here he does
have both feet planted and he is he's
not ready for the contact but he still
stood his ground as somebody 300
plus pounds is flying in the air towards
him I think that's a charge I think it's
a check I think always a charge charge
it is you actually you're giving a call
to the Commissioner of the National
Football League
you love RJ after he lets you into his
is sweet I am a big fan of Roger I'm not
so much a fan of Commissioner Goodell
okay if that makes you can separate the
manifest office yes okay yeah I love Rex
Rex is just phenomenal he's been on the
show we have them on all the time he's
the best and so okay so your show
whiskey Cavalier that you got going on
right now on ABC tell everybody about it
it premiered in late February yeah it's
just like about it it's just a fun show
especially in this time where you know
the politics and it's a tough time here
in America mm-hmm and sometimes you get
home from from work and you don't want
to watch something that is really dark
which a lot of great stuff is yes and
this is light fare it's an hour long but
it's a comedy
it moves fast it's of spies and that
genre but it's goofy I'm the goofiest
one so that's a lot of fun to play but
it's a great come home from work you
don't feel like you know watching White
Walkers again not then you had a tough
day yes so you want to just chill out
and kind of a little escapism it's a
great show so you're saying if you've
had a rough day the Battle of Winterfell
is a little bit too much for it can be a
lot yes although I've already watched it
twice
have you really good Wow I was thinking
the other day like when will I watch
that again yeah like that's it
why did you watch it a second time
already just I'm just that type of fan
plus it was so dark I needed to see what
has we were adjusting our set at home
yeah it was a damn dark yeah I didn't
really mind it I just saw it on the
internet everyone but I was like the
fact that I was leaning in trying to see
I almost made it better for me okay oh
it's when something would jump out on I
was good I know so you watched it a
second time arias got some ups she does
have some ups they get up in the air yes
was that a block or a charge that was it
that was a oh that's a good question Wow
I think he caught he caught her right
with the hand in the air so that's
to charge right but he stopped her set
his feet look the night Kings fee was
definitely set they were said this is
not he extended yeah he didn't take it
he he extended he he created the contact
yes yes he men really are you really
she dropped the knife but she really did
the hardened came up under yeah the foul
dropped the knife
yeah a spoiler alert no I know but at
this point in time right I'm yeah you
haven't seen it Sean Payton gave it up
last hour anyway oh yeah someone tweeted
that got spoiled for them because of
Sean Payton are you serious yeah that's
your own fault at this point this is a
phenomenon Armando Norris a season 24
hours you're done yeah right yeah we're
out of the 72 our Owen yeah you're done
now you're think we all I was in New
York City and couldn't watch it and flew
back Monday and couldn't get on social
media on the flight or anything because
I just couldn't look at anything and I
managed to make it back and watch it a
six hour flight without Twitter go go
Wi-Fi throwback
okay and then Crown Vic what what tell
everybody with this over this just just
premiered at the Tribeca Film Festival
last week yeah it's a I'm really proud
of the film it's about a just the first
day one night in one squad car going
around I have a great character I'm kind
of like Thomas Jane sure is fantastic
yeah and Luke Klein tank and he's the
rookie and Thomas's the is the vet and
they go round for a day and I play a
psycho cop that is in their area in
there and that night and I get to do a
lot of fun bad stuff okay what's fun
okay so you get to play something you
don't normally exactly okay and again
that just premiere did you play the role
of Jack Van Sant in that so get ready
keep an eye out for Crown Vic okay you
are from Lexington Kentucky right yes
sir
I assume you've been to the Kentucky
Derby could have
okay one was one when have you been to
the content oh god is about I can't
remember the year six years ago but it
was it was usually when I go back I
don't go to the Derby stuff because it's
kind of like a Hollywood thing when I go
back I want to see all my friends and
family okay sure but they are they I was
the Grand Marshal for the Kentucky Derby
parade get him I had to say yes to that
just amazing so they reach out to Josh
Hopkins Lexington native saying we want
you to be the Grand Marshal yeah you
know Muhammad Ali's but you know I and
even though being a grand marshal of a
parade is my worst nightmare
why hi look at me everyone that's
terrifying okay and it was even worse
because basically no one knew who I was
so when you're the John you are the
Grand Marshal and were like well at one
point honestly about twenty minutes in I
got used to it and there was a whole
line of people just kind of looking at
me and I waved and they were all just
like this and I said you're supposed to
wave back and they all know but I had to
I needed help
okay I saved myself and because people
weren't drunk enough for the event just
yet and that wasn't people that go to
the Derby it's just kind of like
downtown Louisville feel or expecting to
see Muhammad Ali all right but you're
Kentucky through and through so we
figured you know we we we should have
you in the if you will hot seat in
previous shows we've done this every now
and then every few months or so noticed
when you see commercials for
pharmaceuticals that they could also be
the name of an athlete so we played you
have the name of pharmaceutical or Tour
de France France right or an Olympian
epic athlete we decided to play a game
that you're gonna play gonna guess and
these two can be your help right here
you have I'm gonna say a name and you
have to either say it's the name of a
Kentucky Derby horse or Steven Seagal
straight-to-video movie this is gonna be
hard okay
[Music]
now it's time for Kentucky Derby horse
or straight tip videos Steven Seagal
movie I'm gonna take you to the banks is
there any music for this these are
normal you know okay here you go very
good
first up Kentucky Derby horse or
straight-to-video Steven Seagal movie
into the Sun is that the name of a horse
this weekend at Churchill Downs or the
name of a Steven Seagal
straight-to-video movie I know it's
supposed to rain so I'm just gonna guess
it's Steven Seagal movie you are correct
into the Sun is a 2005 Steven Seagal
mode by the way when I have the logline
for each of these movies when a
government official is killed an
American operative with experience in
the Yakuza culture is brought in to
investigate oh well you had to bring me
into this Sal so he goes to Japan or
something I'm assuming straight-to-video
well I never saw one first try on the
Sun here we go general commander is that
the name of a horse racing for the roses
this weekend or a straight-to-video
seasonal film if you need help what do
you think I'm saying that's a horse you
know I I agree with you there I think
it's general commander is coming soon to
a video outlet near you Steven Seagal
plays Jake Alexander a GRS operative and
his team of young recruits go after the
most dangerous and notorious criminal is
a helper hold on with the help of a Hong
Kong billionaire I mean next one we've
got a few more to go
this is too good once you start you
can't stop it's like eatin Pringles all
right here we go next up war of will war
of will and of course this weekend or
Steven Seagal straight-to-video movie
Seagal movies have three words in the
title yeah war of will hard to kill
I'm gonna go with you you think it's a
Steven Seagal strain yeah yeah war of
will is currently 20 to 1 this week
Kentucky Derby okay next up urban
justice I mean is it the name of a horse
running this weekend or a
straight-to-video Steven Seagal movie
this is satellite notice these are not
in theater Steven Seagal movie in order
to make the cut for this game must be
straight to video Josh Hopkins gotta say
it's a Seagal movie bike and you are
correct in 2007 in urban Justice Segal
played Simon ballister when a dedicated
police officer is murdered Danny Trejo
his father goes on a hunt for the people
responsible urban justice here we go
next one next one next one out of reach
racing if the Kentucky Derby this
weekend or is it he straight to video
Steven Seagal film Josh Hopkins out of
reach or someone to say horse what do
you think Josh you can overrule him it's
is you this is you in the hot seat here
there's nothing at stake so just
understand that out of reach the horse
is fast it's out of reach you can but
it's the Gaul you know he's you know a
former covert agent turned survivalist
discovers that the foster program he's
using to help a young girl is actually a
human trafficking network Lansing heads
overseas to find the girl and shut down
the operational disclosure that's
actually my favorite movie so great if
the next word was full disclosure by the
way could be the one maximum security oh
is it a horse this weekend or is it as
straight-to-video Steven Seagal movie
Josh Hopkins like all like what do you
think it sounds too on-the-nose to be
suitable right
1001 odds maximum security last one Big
Finish in this game Big Finish code of
honor taki Derby horse code of honor
this does sound like a movie though
might follow the same rules the last one
it's really on the nose like Native
American lands he's going to defend some
code of honor a Kentucky Derby horse
this weekend or a Steven Seagal
straight-to-video movie mr. Josh combo
saying I'm saying movie yeah movie
I think horse I'm with you like the last
one got me horse it's fitting that
you're split because it's both and also
2016 movie in which Steven Seagal plays
Colonel Robert Sykes is a stealthy
one-man assault team he will take on
street gangs mobsters and politicians
with extreme prejudice code of honor
available right now in video and also
this weekend this either right or did I
get it wrong you know what when you play
Kentucky Derby horse or Steven Seagal
straight-to-video moving everyone's a
winner it's a good game for Millennials
hey thanks for playing Josh Hopkins
thanks for having I'm a nice whiskey
Cavalier episode tonight on ABC is a
nice parting gift for you whiskey
Cavalier Wednesday at 10:00 p.m. Eastern
on whiskey Cavalier by the way is
two-to-one odds to be appear tonight
good to see you bud mr. Josh Hopkins on
both Twitter and Instagram for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app